so attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder is a very misunderstood
psychiatric disorder it's real it
literally five to eight percent of the
population has this disorder and the
important part is that it's a variation
on normal so you have children who are
more hyperactive more impulsive more
inattentive than other children their
developmental age and it is a lifetime
disorder so that it will look slightly
different obviously between a
preschooler a school-age child a high
school student or an adult but there's
still a consistency of inattention
impulsivity and hyperactivity in fact
most often we see that hyperactivity
disappears as someone gets older and so
when they're in their late adolescence
and early adulthood that symptom seems
to go away and if we are able to look at
the brains of children who have ADHD
they look different than typical
children and in fact an important study
was done about 15 years ago that
followed kids over a decade who had
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
and these were children who had never
taken medication this was a group of
kids who met the diagnostic criteria
were studied at the National Institute
of Mental Health and had parents who
said under no circumstances will we
treat our kids with Ritalin or any kind
of medication and were compared to a
group of typical or normal children the
same age and they found that there were
significant differences in the frontal
lobe and in the cerebellum the frontal
lobe is where you have your executive
functioning where you're able to
prioritize which items should I attack
first what's the important things that I
should do today and how do I get that
done before I go to item two three four
and five that are tackling me as far as
my daily tasks and the cerebellum is
where coordination is and so it's really
interesting that as these kids got older
and hit adolescence they're Sarah
Belem started to look more like the same
size as the typical normal kids and it
would explain why the hyperactivity
symptom seems to diminish and yet the
frontal lobes still seemed significantly
smaller than the typical normal child
so I think it's important for us to
realize that our brains are filled with
neurotransmitters these are brain
chemicals that move from one part of the
brain to another and take messages with
them the three big neurotransmitters
would be dopamine norepinephrine and
serotonin and when you have attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder you use
your dopamine and your neuro epinephrine
faster in your brain than the average
person and when you don't have enough of
that you become an attentive or you
become more impulsive or you're more
hyperactive the centers of the brain
that are smaller on these patients who
have ADHD seem to be very rich in
dopamine and in norepinephrine so it's
very nice that there's a neuroanatomical
reason for us to be sure that the
chemicals that we're talking about are
equal now you can't take dopamine or
norepinephrine or even serotonin and get
it to your brain because there's
something in our body called the
blood-brain barrier protects the brain
and the spinal cord and the
neurotransmitters those brain chemicals
that move back and forth in that space
and so we give medications that kind of
change or trick the brain so that we
allow dopamine or norepinephrine in the
case of kids with ADHD to hang around
longer in the brain to make them look
more typical these medications whether
they're ritalin which is very similar to
focalin and a group that's called meth
methamphetamine versus dextra
amphetamine or dexedrine or adderall on
which is a little more potent both of
them create about the same types of
chemical response which is to make
dopamine and norepinephrine more
available but their short acting
medicines they last anywhere from four
hours to about 10 hours and once the
medicines out of your system
you're right back to where you were at
baseline so there is really nothing
permanent about this this is a treatment
not